I couldn't take care of my business I
wouldn't you know and my feet it kept
walking to the first walk I kept bumping
into it so I wouldn't I couldn't take
some business so I told her to get
amputated nine maybe 12 months ago you
cut your toe off yeah and I haven't made
the next appointment so this toast
starting to hurt I don't know maybe my
son or my sister come find me down here
and take me to the dog
so Jessica where did you grow up where
are you from I grew up in South Central
47th and Central I went to 49th Street
School Los Angeles California
tell me about your family no my mom died
when I was like seven I guess and my
grandmother raised me and my grandmother
with me every day for anything with
extension car I went to bed too long
maybe 10 but I got a whip and I always
run away and uh
boys I uh how do you like boys I think
they took advantage of me and that's how
I am
tried a PCP one time and then I didn't
know where I was at but I was but that
kid when I came to what age was that
that was like maybe 16-17 but I liked
the PCP too yeah I thought it made me
pretty
how would you describe your childhoods
I mean I went to school but I was mad I
didn't wear my clothes two times and I
ran away a lot so it was just like this
but to me it was just like this so
I never met my daddy nobody mentions him
so there's no doubt I think I was the
dad of her family actually because I was
more the Billy but bully and I had the
sister and your grandparents no my
grandmother raised me she didn't have a
husband either
the uh
your ass has to be great I have to do
because I appreciate I peed in there I
don't understand how she woke me up at
night and whipped me with a cinch clock
as I pee into that that something that
really hurts sometimes and you know all
I know now is I just like getting high
and the people outside they feel more
like Tamil
the people on the street they feel like
family yes and my family my family
how long have you been on Skid Row I've
been uh since 1981
this is like in 1981 yeah and then once
I moved closer uh on it's a street like
Washington it was a gas station and then
we used from the ice pump gas and I got
this and then I went to jail for um
being on the property so many times and
then I beat somebody up in jail but we
had drugs in jail too yeah drugs have
been a part of your life yeah yes I like
yeah yeah and it seems like it made me
feel better
yeah sometimes I have to give oral sex
for drugs but I really don't like it and
then I always argue with the guy because
I'm not gonna keep sucking on your dick
so no drugs and I can go recycle or go
back on my tent and just
see what I got maybe I could sell and I
really don't have a tent because
somebody always stealing stuff and
moving stuff I had a nice basket so
where do you sleep do I sleep at right
now I sleep right by um eighth and um
right past spring and one block over
because it's like a little parking lot
then sometime I sleep on Pico
um Pico and two blocks from Broadway
that way it's a little lot it's just on
the sidewalk yeah but I have cardboard
or something I've got and I had um found
a air masters they were slapped so I I
folded three times and it's cool because
it feels like um feels like um heater or
something when you're getting that
plastic
what is your drug now my drug I like oh
I like Crystal and then I'll hit I'll
hit crab just kind of like um
kind of calm down but but Crystal makes
me motivate me move yeah
y'all will recycle
I like to go recycle now do you have
children huh yeah I have a son but he's
with his dad and that's I haven't seen
my son like maybe 20 years I don't know
where he stayed with his daddy because
he made him
anyway I didn't know it I didn't have to
do nothing
so whatever their family got it or
whatever I don't meet his family I just
thought he was a good guy
and he stole my money at my socket so he
he's not doing drugs wherever he's at
but I know he's with a girlfriend of
mine a girl that I went to school with
so [ __ ] him [ __ ] damn [ __ ] him I don't
talk about them no more okay please you
ever been in love yeah have you ever
been I love my baby daddy but it's not
good because he's cheated and he
switched somebody else somebody girl he
got to even think about me he took my
son from
that's all I know
what emotions do you go through living
down here oh man some days I just get up
and I don't want to oh yeah but when I
go
recycling I find me something to eat
that's nice
that's when I go sit down and uh just
start crying but it's good because I
find some good food sometimes it's
sealed up and the people give you food
but sometimes I have to sell the food
the person give me okay
just when I wake up
Abby
tired I just want to lay back down but I
get up because I know if I don't get up
now if I go up to a deep sleep
somebody's gonna steal a chance and they
always steal your basket then my
Walker's gone my my wheelchair's gone so
this guy I got this one in Sydney I know
once I get back I take it for two days
so far and when I go back down the
street I know you're going to go tell me
like [ __ ] you better get you better
give me something uh let me put you up
because I don't care I don't care about
the man talking talking [ __ ]
I think the man like the man anyway I
don't give a [ __ ] about this piece is it
her being a female here on skid row no
uh money if you ain't no punk ass [ __ ]
I ain't no punk [ __ ] I don't I don't
I'll hit you back if you hit me back I'm
good I'm nice
um shoot I love myself I think I don't
love myself and I'm personally don't
love himself I don't know but it's
terrible living out here but it's
wonderful and one thing sometimes we
laughing sometimes we fight
yeah I'll see a different music but if
you dance and act like you like the
music the [ __ ] man gonna do the
fact that man the man turn the music off
if you start dancing and like the music
player they'll turn the damn music off
you know that's stupid that's mean and
it's evil and it's only because last
time he saw him getting some dope he
might help me out help me out look out
for you I'm not giving that man no more
of my jokes he never give me nothing
else you don't share with me people
don't share and then they ask you for
theirs
does it seem like your life revolves
around drugs yeah but and then to uh I
have a lot of things I think about
um I thought about like one place I was
at and then I used to hang out smoking
drugs but it was like bad because it's
all I can't be changed streets for drugs
but then there's people always like uh
[ __ ] oh don't pick pennies up let's get
left
these pins I can take them I can take
the pennies and uh so I had a dream that
a dream that I had a fight with I seen
the faces of the guys and um but then uh
I um they just told me I can't come by
drugs there no more and I woke up I got
my knees I prayed because it was so real
but it's easy good because you can have
a seat and do your drugs but people are
still harassing and then I've been
violated and raped I already read about
you guys name um their name was John and
uh Ike and they took me in this
um like a house on room bacon house a
long time Lego but but uh
background where I was raised that by
50s in South Central
and then they um act like he was going
to give me some drugs or whatever and I
was talking together and then all of a
sudden the other one came back and said
she didn't do no work but I was high and
drunk so he said well you're gonna do
this you're going to oral and then every
time I try to run the guy that was he
choking he would choking and then
um then uh then he caught me there and
then he made me get on my knees and he
said now you gotta check my um
because when he he told me so much you
feel like I'm a dinosaur I'm saying yeah
so anyway
um
then
um then I made me get on my knees at the
end of God it was in the bedroom and so
um he had a hammer and then he said he's
gonna [ __ ] me in my ass while I took his
friend dick and then I beat his friend
dick and then he was still bleeding but
the one name I think his name was Ike he
could choke right he really choked man
every time I try to go and then um
so anyway his dick was bleeding in the
next two or I gotta try to go again and
I kissed me and I was scared of him I
understand trying to grab it and then um
I choked me again and then John's on the
Johnny here he laying in the bed did you
go into the houses they can actually win
it and the Masters was white and then he
still was laying on the bed and I'm
supposed to [ __ ] him with his bloody
dick and he tried [ __ ] with the
bloody dick and then they they let me go
they let me go out I called the police
and then
maybe uh whatever since I've been down
here I've seen them guys just walking
across to you like they ain't been to
jail or nothing and I just called y'all
just act like I don't see him but I know
they look at me like uh there she go we
should say hi
things happen like that
no
what's your biggest fear no I'm dying on
the dying sitting around people
dying and sitting around people
standing sit around people because it
was shooting
um some shootings when I was down there
like um seventh and bro and somebody got
killed I wasn't there then once I think
about done I just really try to get me
some uh strong vodka somebody take me
out of you know in my feelings and don't
want it because when I spoke with Chris
I'm kind of cool and happy if you had
your life to live all over again what
would you have done differently
um I really am I asked to go to a foster
home and then I got my boyfriend and
just smoke weed
that sounds better bro
yep I would be done
and maybe I would act better
I don't know if you still have hope of
of getting your life together or getting
off the streets anything like that yeah
maybe
maybe I don't think I want to live in
those buildings with these people
because I don't like being closed in and
I hear voices sometimes you'd rather be
on the streets than yeah I can hear cars
but and close places I hear voices
telling me I'm not worth it and you
should just go
you know just go walk away you give you
don't got a sign you don't got to have
me you're you're stupid how old do you
know me I'm 70. 70. never I'm 61. I know
I like oh I'm 16. yeah you're like yeah
so you've been down here 40.
I've been out here in the streets doing
Yorkshire since 1981. Christmas day at
that
Christmas nails when I started I tried
from somebody in my neighborhood and
they feel good they tasted good and I
was like [ __ ] the world [ __ ] you my
family was like oh you're a drunk man
you're a weed idiot y'all bring people
here
I start stealing [ __ ]
my grandma's she got to go and then
still see what let me in sometime in the
shower and I still feel [ __ ] because
they were mean to me you know they were
very mean and I used to watch dishes and
I used to do things for them and I used
to get them Christmas presents out of my
recycle I mean I kept cans a lot of them
my grandmother said I can't keep her
back I'm asking her yard and all that I
was nice to them so how come I can't
come and eat a nice sandwich and then
get out the refrigerator you go and you
weed in here so
Focus sometimes I stole food at the
refrigerator and act like I was just
getting water just to survive and I
would bring some food this year like a
hot dog from alone how about him one
time we couldn't cook it nowhere and the
lady said the lady said Myra picked that
hammer I said no I didn't she said yes
she did got it live and told her my
grandma told me to pick a hammer because
when I was little I'm good I used to go
pick a ham up
did God said he was gonna make a break
it's not funny but it's stupid I'm kind
of like
um I feel like I'm losing oxygen in my
brain I was up two days sorry
you know go to these cans can I get I
said can you do these three dollars and
then these cans I know what they might
have Jessica what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life uh not to be drunk and go a
man
not to go with me just drink my liquor
and hang out out in the world outside
the street so everybody can see me don't
go no strange man
because they will try to take your body
and make you suck your dick and all that
old [ __ ] and then you'd be half as dead
at the hospital and you better get all
that [ __ ] my family made me take it easy
when I got like
not three weeks three weeks one guy with
a Scarface and I got in the car down
here down there and I get in the car and
give me the race y'all shut up let me
see shut the [ __ ] up I was you say you
black [ __ ] are suckling Mexican dicks
he'd be putting a razor on me I almost
got out the window the mirror the window
was down there I had to leave I got I
just started because the lights came on
said yeah
women